of course you're known for freestyling
are you doing a lot of freestyling and
Quarantine right now only to my friends
only in videos not fit for TV but you
know if you wanted to if you wanted to
make up a song we could do that if you
want to like I'll try it if you like
very rusty yeah that's okay we're we're
all playing on the bar has been lowered
for all of us would you do first thing
when you woke up this morning I
overslept
I slept later than I normally do I
stumbled out of bed I made myself a
shake with spinach and some fruit in it
hmm
I then and wrestled with my dog what's
that Loki okay
yeah let's see what else did I do
I did three push-ups what's the most
exciting you know it this is the problem
it's quarantine so this would be it
talking to you this is the highlight of
my day is happy as a zoom conference
with lin-manuel Miranda nothing's gonna
beat that you know I had a conversation
with someone in your house this morning
that I don't know someone said something
that maybe they shouldn't have said yes
my son loves to okay boomer me he's 14
and so all he does is put me down for
not being tech savvy and I asked him a
very simple question I thought it was a
simple I asked a question that I thought
was interesting about my computer and
setting up the zoom conference and he
was like okay boomer and I what was the
question it was something like when I
hit the spacebar why does it not click
back into the other window something I
don't even understand because I'm I'm
not good I'm not good at computers I'm
really not so and I shouldn't be doing
anything I should but we're alone here I
don't have anybody at work I usually had
people come in and go and it's all set
and lin-manuel Miranda's there and go
but now no I have to figure it out all
right
and were there any interactions you have
today that we're like actually really
great like heartening like we're gonna
be okay I actually I'm gonna again this
may be cheating but I'm gonna go to you
I like I really like what you're doing I
like what you're doing for Broadway and
theatres and Times Square and and I I
like that I get to wear this shirt that
matches my eyes that was a gift from you
that's a big deal to me so I like that
okay great what time do we got sorry oh
man it was late it was
I slept till 9:00 this morning I'm sorry
I slept till 9:00 you have wrong kids
yes I do
[Music]
okay
yes that was great yeah you know and I
this this is gonna get me incredible
this is gonna make my son's day because
he's a huge fan huge fan of yours as is
my daughter and so the fact that you
sang this song were you mock me and call
me okay boomer that she's fired by him
wow this is this is huge oh that was
fantastic and I will gladly share the
rights to that with you oh yeah
fantastic yeah there was a little Dana
Carvey creeping in because I've been
listening to your Dana Carvey podcast so
much broccoli always a hats off to the
brilliant Dana Carvey let me make sure
that was fantastic man that was great I
have to say all you need is a little
more time in quarantine polish that up
you've got a great musical about another
important historic figure I want to
mention something you're doing amazing
work in addition to what we've already
talked about you're doing amazing work
with Hispanic Federation and something
called edu ham at home you want to talk
about that for a second
yeah sure there are two different things
both sort of really important right now
we worked with the Hispanic Federation
for a really long time we worked with
them a lot in the wake of Hurricane
Maria but right now we're setting up an
Emergency Assistance Fund basically
because you know Latino communities have
been among the hardest hit through this
pandemic and so it's an emergency fund
for organizations that already existed
or are
doing great work in fields like Public
Health and immigration and and basically
servicing Latin ex needs and then a jam
I'm really excited about edge a ham is
something we've been doing for years
with the Hamilton show we basically
created a curriculum for schools when
they're coming to visit Hamilton they
write their own pieces they perform them
for us on stage at the Rogers than we do
in QA and we perform the show for them
and we're we're making that curriculum
public so basically if you're bored with
your kids you have the Hamilton
curriculum at your disposal now to
basically learn to create using primary
sources and really excited about that
let me make sure I get the word out to
get some of the great clothing that
supports Broadway cares kovat 19
emergency fund go-to Chirico comm is
that correct yeah okay we're gonna make
sure that we put that all up here down
at the bottom because we want to get the
word out great
sir you are doing you're doing God's
work I swear to god I'm such a huge fan
and an admirer of you not just as an
artist but a person so thank you thank
you you had to do it didn't you you had
to do it hey thank you so much that was
amazed